[Musique]
la semaine devait marquer un tournant
sur la question du droit de vote le
président s'étant déplacé à atlanta
mardi ville natale de martin luther king
pour envoyer un message fort
je suis l'un d'eux me tenir coi face aux
tentatives de certains et un pour
restreindre le droit de vote at il
martelé allant même jusqu'à approuver
une réforme des règles sénatoriales pour
empêcher les républicains et de faire de
l'obstruction
mais 48 heures plus tard les grandes
ambitions se sont butés au camouflet
infligé par deux sénateurs démocrates
alors djoman chine de la virginie
occidentale et colton cinéma de
l'arizona crois qu'un coup de force au
sénat ne créerait que plus de divisions
sans leur appui pas de changement des
règles pas de changement des règles pas
de projet de loi adopté joe biden admis
lui même qu'il ne sait pas s'il pourra
tenir sa promesse
autre front autre échec du moins en
partie dans sa lutte contre la pandémie
joe biden voulaient forcer la
vaccination des employés des
établissements de santé qui reçoivent du
financement fédéral et des employés des
entreprises comptant au moins 100
travailleurs la cour suprême a suspendu
cette obligation pour les entreprises
jugeant que l'administration avait
outrepassé ses pouvoirs la maison
blanche on est maintenant réduite à
demander au pdg d'imposer eux mêmes la
vaccination
à cela s'ajoutent les frustrations
exprimées concernant l'inflation
galopante la pénurie de tests rapides
les directives la santé publique jugent
et changeante et mélangeant tu les
médias américains parlent d'une semaine
brutal pour le président alors que
s'amorce l'année des élections de mi
mandat ici vous la vallée radio-canada
washington